en fait l'idée là c'est déterminer
enfants de bagdhis qu'on est prêt à
aller quoi 4 avril 2018
les lycéens sont dans la rue il dénonce
la loi vidal une réforme des universités
qui selon eux renforcera la sélection
sur leurs pancartes des références au
printemps 68 aujourd'hui mai 68 c'est un
modèle pour nous construire la
convergence des luttes en finir avec la
sélection lutter contre les attaques
dont on et dont on est les victimes
aujourd'hui
depuis 50 ans la jeune génération
s'inspire de mai 68 1986 des centaines
de milliers de manifestants s'opposent
au projet loi devaquet 2006 les lycéens
les étudiants dénoncent le projet cpe le
contrat première embauche 2016 partout
en france
de vastes cortèges contre la loi travail
et de longues nuits de boue des
assemblées citoyennes pour imaginer une
autre société
autant de mouvements de contestation
dans lesquelles la jeunesse se mobilise
ce qu'a insufflé 68 c'est vraiment cette
prise de parole et cette idée de relever
la tête de ne plus accepter passivement
et de manière résigné ce qui nous est
proposé
on n'a pas connu mai 68 mais évidemment
il ya pensé parce que effectivement ont
contesté le cpe mais il y avait aussi
cette aspiration à un autre monde
là la jeunesse avait droit à un moment
de s'emparer de cette question quel sera
notre avenir et comment demain on va
travailler et vivre comme nos ennemis
en 2006 kévin bodé est en terminale
pendant trois semaines et nuit il mène
la lutte anti cpe au lycée marguerite de
navarre à alençon autour de barricades
et de feux de camp dont les traces sont
encore visibles au sol des discussions
interminables jour et nuit
ces deux là où partent et les
manifestations et on rejoignait d'autres
lycées au cif
c'est toujours été joyeux toujours jolie
empruntant houdan l'entousiasme ils ont
fait l'expérience de l'insubordination
et de la liberté d'expression
et comme leurs aînés voulu porter au
pouvoir
l'imagination
[Musique]